you're a really fun person to talk to i
enjoy talking to you i truly feel like
when
when you have drew barrymore's attention
you truly have it
[Music]
i'm about to do another art of the
interview which is a series that is very
personal to me because
i really hold journalism
dear to my heart the reason we call it
the art of the interview is because the
way that people
do their research and pose questions
can be the game changer not only in a
conversation
but in the way that we learn about that
person
or the world in general and i can't
think of anyone
that i have a deeper respect for more
admiration
and just ah i want to learn i want to be
i want it all with samantha b being
asked to do this
is like a huge thrill for me so i'm here
let's do it let's break it down let's
talk now
you when you were a kid i heard
that you had a news
i did fake news when i was a kid
or i i did i would do recordings
of myself as a newscaster like comedy
like comedy news i was maybe like six or
seven years old
i called it news for goofs and so i had
like a little
cassette recorder like just like this
little box
with cassette tapes and a microphone and
i think that i
was doing an impression of kermit doing
an impression of a journalist
but i was really super into it and then
i would record
people's conversations i would hide
under the kitchen table and record
everybody talking
it's very you cannot anyway i spied on
my family
also well you were ahead of the game you
and george orwell
um because that's happening now uh
everywhere everywhere everywhere
i love that
story about you because
i really care about the news i
i'm obsessed with it
and i always have been since i can
remember
and i liked my news with
a flare of comedy and
so i was so curious as to what your
origin story of news for goofs was
because i loved late night and i
loved saturday night live totally and
i was so curious as to what your
influences are and the kermit the frog
is like i am freaking out i know exactly
what you're talking about
yeah he would be like kermit the frog
here
and do a whole report on the weather or
whatever in a trench coat like a
reporter all these things and also i'm
like you
i watched snl 2 growing up if i was
like at my mom's house she would be
watching it and i'd be
she'd be like don't tell your
grandmother you're up at
midnight watching you know watching jane
curtin
be an anchor on you know what i mean on
weekend update but
i would like watch jane curtain be kind
of a sure
and they were doing jokes they were
doing more pure jokes i mean these are
shared memories from when we were like
little kids
and eventually they went on to inform
entire careers so
anyway i guess the point is what are my
kids going to do as their jobs
i don't know now i'm like what am i
doing to them i don't know
i do know that as a human being who did
grow up too fast
i too was hosting snl at six and
watching
all of that world and immersed in
anything i had access to
everything and david letterman was my
first crush
as was ted koppel ted cop
oh my god i think i can get behind
a ted couple crush that makes sense i
was always
really attracted to smart and funny
that that's the hottest combo to me
period
and then i think as i grew up you know
maybe i had a crush when i was a kid
you know on these certain men it was
like who is informing my world
who is telling me about what i need to
know
who's giving me my medicine with so
much comedy sugar and i am just
eating it up like bite after bite
i love information that can be delivered
to me in a way that is entertaining
and i don't even need it to always be
funny but i want it to be gripping
i want the story to be told correctly
so that it pulls me along how do you
have the beverness to say some of the
things that you do
the truth is that i have like an
incredible team of people
i'm the face of all of this but i'm the
face of
you know i'm the forward-facing person
of a team of 65 people
it's not just like sami going like make
mops
you know it's really it's written and my
head writers are incredible and my
producers are incredible and
my research you know we're a very
research driven show so we're
making jokes but it's all on top of
you know it's it the foundation of that
is
a really diligent like very
exacting uh like highly performing
research team who just do an incredible
job of sorting through you know the the
points that we want to hit the points
that make
we're storytelling you know we're really
truly as a team
storytelling and putting jokes on top of
that
we all feel angry about the same thing
sad about the same things happy about
the same things like we're
very focused on being on the right side
of history i think
do you have a jiminy cricket on your
shoulder
that says you do want this for the long
game
and therefore there's
a lack of vanity
that's possible i mean that is super
possible like there's a part of me
that's always
there's a part of me that every six
months goes i'm gonna i'm gonna
start an organic farm like forget it i
raise bees out here this is what i want
to do for the rest of my life and then i
go
okay well what about on day two that was
a great idea on day one
but honestly sometimes you just need a
two-week break
and then at the end of the two-week
break you go well now i have all these
other ideas
and so i do think well i think you're in
it for the long haul i feel like i'm in
it for the long haul
and that's exciting like not always
knowing what the next chapter is but
knowing that there will be one
i really gravitated towards wanting to
be in all those different positions some
of which were
had nothing to do with the way i looked
writing and directing and producing
um and wasn't about me being in front of
a camera
and i think it was a real blessing
because
i'm like there are things beyond this
that i'm so
attracted and invigorated and feeling
whole from
yeah you feel like liberated
that you know you can do a million
things
yes or for sure and you must also
like i do definitely remember
a stage of life early in my career which
was very much about sitting around
and waiting for my agent to call me and
they rarely called
and it was lonely and i was
scared and like always checking the
phone to see if
that there was something wrong with the
dial tone like i probably spent a couple
of years dwelling in that place of like
i gotta be home in case the phone rings
in case someone wants me for something
and that is
not a place where i can like live i
don't recommend that some people are
super into that and that's
great i cannot do that
i don't want to wait anymore for someone
to tell me they're interested in me for
a thing i want to tell people what i'm
interested in
and have them go oh yes well i can see
now
that you know how to make a show from
start to finish we're so alike it's like
freaking me out right now i used to talk
about the magic telephone
i'm like that magic telephone not only
doesn't exist
i want to build that phone yes i want to
build the phone i want to
pick it up and call other people with it
that's right yeah exactly i
couldn't agree more you already
collaborate with your husband jason
jones we do
we definitely have done that in the past
for sure
we had adjoining desks at the daily show
and we would spend our idle time like
if we had downtime there we would spend
time sitting across from each other
and working on scripts we actually have
a very good
balance together we would each argue for
our own kind of creative perspective
um but we never we usually i would say
99
of the time we never made it personal
which was really great and we would
disagree
constantly but we would find our way
through the materials and i actually
think that that was
the key to success in collaborating that
way
take me through like just a work session
well okay so jason and i work
very differently to with the go with an
end goal in mind like we've always had
because we met we met when i was in my
i'm a little older than him so i think i
was like 26 27 when we started
he was about 23. and so
early in our relationship i looked to
him i was actually like what are you
what are you doing like why are you why
are you working so
hard in a way and so i learned a lot
about work ethic actually from him
and did you start as co-workers and
learned how to have a relationship or
did you start with a relationship and
learn how to be co-workers
we started as sort of as co-workers
we were we were in our office romance i
think that one's still safe to say
i think so but it was more like
children's theater romance
so we were doing now we can't do it
again yeah you brought your children
into it
no so it was we were doing a play it was
like a touring kind of production
and we weren't in the same cast we were
adjacent so we were part of kind of a
little bit of work travel together and
that's actually how we started having
conversations we
each thought that we were just
developing a friendship
and then it grew really organically out
of that
over time a lot of people say a
friendship is that like
invaluable foundation for sure
what is your intention with your current
show
i think that
i think that you know we've been on the
air this is our sixth season
my it really took me a long time to
actually figure out what that was i
don't know if you're
in this space right now but i would say
that for the first two years of my show
i barely knew who i was because i just
was like
it's so much work to make
to put a thing on the air you're doing
it
five days a week or you know a lot more
than me
and uh it took me a long time it takes a
long time to
just calm down like there's so much
happening you're answering
so many questions and doing so many
different things
it takes a minute to just go to drop
into it it actually takes a bit
for the penny to drop of the full
experience
and i think now that
one of my intentions with the show
is to like just
try and make the world a better place
than when i started just to leave
television
a little bit better than how it was when
i started like we've done some
i've made mistakes i hope that people
can look back and go
oh tv was a little bit better in general
after that show went off the air because
it's a female-led you know it's a
female-led show
it's a female-led staff we
made innovations in the in in the way
that we did things or we tried we were
always trying
to make tv just incrementally a little
better for the people who will come
behind
and who knew that we would be thanking
kermit the frog
oh my god i just i love it so much
because you do have a goodness but
a spine that is so infallible
and a wit that is so juicy and
desirable and
i just i'm i've been a happier person
since you've been on the air whether it
was in the daily show
or your own talk show you're also
really helping people understand a lot
of things that other people aren't
talking about
in that very well researched very
journalistic way
it's um it is very
important what you're doing and i love
it and boy do you give that
importance with that sugar that just
who doesn't want that thank you so much
you're a really fun person to talk to i
enjoy
talking to you i truly feel like when
when you have drew barrymore's attention
you truly have it
i i just i love you so much and you are
making television better and you are
breaking
ceilings and grounds and
i think a lot of our influences in the
way we grew up
sounds very similar a lot of our process
sounds really similar
um and that's
humbling to me because i'm like
i just love you so much so that's cool
like let's build that telephone thank
you
samantha b pleasure talking to you as
always thank you so much
you